when you get on the horse you're on the
horse and you take the horse out to the
what to the racetrack to like the voting
booth that I'm talking about like oh
it's the paddock that we call it the
pattern or The Paddock is the circle the
little circle where like you know the
horses run
um before we get on top of the horses
they like you know there's like the
people can look at them you know uh if
you're gonna bear your like the gamut
you're gonna look and see which course
you like and you can make that look at
them then uh then uh the trainers like
put like put us on the horse and then we
we go to the racetrack and do the warm
the pre-warm up before the Before the
Race okay so if I'm a batter right which
Nick is but if I'm a bear and I go to
the paddock is there anything I can look
for as a batter that can give me any
sort of insight as to how the the only
thing that I can that I can that I can
that I can give you and a tip sort of
you know try to look for horses they're
not too nervous or sweaty you know
because they're usually are like uh
they're not gonna perform well like most
of those horses are like you know
they're too nervous and so sweaty
already
um
spending a lot of energy you know being
being like so
um a sweaty horse dude
besides that I'm I'm horrible my wife
told me like never to say to give her
any tips about horse racing because she
always loses me notice she liked it
better now she does once in a while be
like oh my God I'm training this course
that I really really like you know you
should put some some money on him you
know and then uh the horse will run
third to Fourth and then she'll be like
I don't want no more of your tips I
think one female
um horse won the Kentucky Derby wow yeah
I don't remember what's the name of of
the horse but yeah a female is not very
common you know but like yeah no they
can run there's no restriction
whatsoever
for a female horse not to enter they you
just have to qualify if you good enough
to qualify you can you can run so more
more commonly a lot of the horses that
you ride are male horses
do you notice a difference in the horses
oh yeah yeah oh yeah the girls are more
feisty
you have to treat them different
dude oh they're so gotta take them to
the movies oh you have to be so kind and
nice to them and open the door yep yeah
they're more yeah you have to be
sustained outside of the stable just
waiting for you to open the door to it
yeah yeah yeah they're so so different
so so they really yeah wow I have a lot
of language feelings with with female
horses really a lot of what Phillies
luck you know but they they run really
well for me really yeah maybe they like
you huh yes okay yeah I can see it man
yeah handsome guy I could see it Nick
did you have something else that kind of
popped up uh just with like uh the
gambling like
how
there's always such a heavy favorite
where are they getting that information
from what is that based off of if
because the horses don't have a ton of
history behind them from what I
understand they race for like a year or
two so like how do they know who's the
favorite and yeah no they they we had
like they have the past performances you
know you you can see for example um or
they they um we they record the workouts
as well you know so if a horse is
working in Good Times you know so that
tend to be the oh how are they doing it
you know there's cameras feeling on them
in the mornings how they're working and
things like that you know and is all
that available to the public if you want
to research yeah yeah that's available
you buy it
there is people on there is like the the
the hardcore handicappers the core
gamblers you know that they you go you
buy this book and you study this book
and you can see the past performance
what they have all kinds of descriptions
whether the horse did uh If he if he got
in any kind of trouble broccoli from the
gate oh they have all kinds of things
you know dang
bit figures and all this type of thing
it goes too crazy and can a horse spit
do they spit I don't think so no I don't
think those are like llamas I think yeah
right yeah yeah you're right Winning
Colors genuine risk and regret yeah the
only Phillies to win the Kentucky Derby
it doesn't look like any female jockeys
have won no no no they haven't won I
don't think there's a female joke hmm
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one